je vais vous dire le prénom c'est relou
ça plaît allez allez les verts
je l'ai rencontré aux États-Unis allez
et on retourne
[Applaudissements]
si je connaissais très bien sa famille
je connaissais notamment sa tenté son
oncle non la comtesse du bien
je suis sorti avec le sosie d'Ali Berry
Simone du Berry
non je ne suis jamais sorti avec une
américaine mais c'est dur jamais
pourquoi parce que j'ai les règles d'or
je suis franco-français je suis français
jusqu'au bout des doigts
et j'ai eu des j'ai eu des j'ai eu des
correspondantes américaines qui sont
venus en France et j'étais un petit peu
leur guide et il s'est rien passé les
deux dormaient dans ma chambre puisque
on a qu'une chambre à la maison et toute
la nuit
les
appeler frites à les chipstel les
jumelles de la pérides
c'est un copain à vous you
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ah génial
tu viens de résumer 40 ans de ça
[Musique]
[Rires]
tu es revenu dans l'émission et c'est
dans cette émission et on peut repartir
aussi vite
je le sais tu as envie de rester
si possible
[Rires]
de Clermont
vous avez fait or hexagone octogone
non non bien sûr
[Musique]
Rachel de Cuba
mais frère arrête de charrier mais elle
a quel âge
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
super bien on va samedi au lycée de la
petite tous les deux ou non ma fille
habite en France et sa maman aussi ouais
je vais noter tu sais sur
cette dame alors elle
était mannequin
mannequin
une mannequin
en fait on va garder que le mot van
donc
tu l'as connu que j'épouse en même temps
il y a pas mal
excuse-moi non non mais
au contraire un défilé de mannequin là
c'était très difficile il y a eu des
enquêtes naturelles sur moi comme elle
était amoureuse c'est fou
le premier regard elle voulait un visa
et quoi donc là elle est en train de
elle est en train de défiler conasse et
là tu la regardes elle se dit c'est ce
gars c'est lui c'était quoi les
éclairages là-bas
[Rires]
alors
il s'appelait ignac
on fait connaissance vous je connais
elle est sortie avec un Canadien je me
rappelle voilà je connais je connais
toutes les histoires Delphine Valérie
Géraldine je connais toi on voilà on
fait connaissance
j'étais en vacances
et comment il t'a pécho c'était quoi
piscine
idiot aquatique
[Rires]
les gars alors
on va au Sancho ou pas peut-être lourd
tu connais tu étais où c'était au
Moonlight
des grosses boîtes à 17 ans tu es super
content tu dis super il y a pas les
parents
[Applaudissements]
on en a rien à voir c'est un truc de fou
c'est ouf d'ailleurs tu es incroyable
c'est une force quand même
si on dirait une patinoire
il lui demande il lui demande si elle si
elle n'est pas en espagnol mais
qu'est-ce qu'on a mais c'est
vachement intéressant Quentin c'est
mignon
arrête de nous casser les couilles
[Applaudissements]
3h du matin
mais c'est tout ce que tu sais que je
peux tenir la vérité dis-moi
je suis parti avec un ami en vacances
cet été tu sais comment on l'appeler
[Rires]
franchement c'est vrai vas-y parle un
peu espagnol
non avec ma mère
[Rires]
il est con bah oui Pascal oui on l'a
Pascal
c'est un espagnol qui va finir dans
Faites entrer l'accusé là
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu as l'air d'un pervers
je prépare ça on va le voir ça dans un
instant dans un instant
royal
qui arrive après juste après Eva
Longoria que du lourd Bam Bam Bam Bam tu
réfléchis à ta place je suis en train de
boire le public
[Applaudissements]